[Musique]
nous sommes le 26 juin bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 les
invités les titres 38,6 pour cent c'est
le pourcentage de femmes à l'assemblée
nationale après les dernières élections
une nette progression par rapport à la
précédente mandature l'association elle
aussi se satisfait de ce changement mais
reste vigilante
armelle d'année sa vice-présidente ce
nous on parlera et puis nous parlerons
également des risques de transmission du
vih avec jérôme andré directeur de hf
prévention l'été approche à sortir
couvert est toujours une nécessité nous
verrons aussi que l'association va voir
son nombre de missions augmenter dans
les prochains mois et il y aura
également de nouveaux locaux on va en
parler avec vous germandrée bonsoir on
se lance dans l'instant mais tout
d'abord nous parlons encore un peu de de
politique de parité en tout cas avec
vous armelle d'année à vice présidente
elle aussi association qui se bat
justement pour cette égalité hommes
femmes au niveau au niveau politique les
élections législatives je le disais
qu'ils ont amené une nouvelle
recomposition de l'hémicycle
rajeunissement pardon mais pas
uniquement 38,6 pour cent est des
députés sont des députés avec un e elles
n'étaient que 27%
elle sous la précédente mandature déjà
pour commencer vous félicite et
j'imagine de 7,7 progression nette
oui tout à fait d'autant plus que
c'était assez inattendu puisque en 2000
en 2012 y avait 40% de femmes candidates
elles n'ont été que 27% et élus bon là
il y avait un petit progrès 42%
il y avait un doublement des pénalités
financières pour les partis qui ne
présentait pas autant de candidats quels
candidats devront ceci dit les partis
les grands partis n'ont pas présenté
autant de candidates quand deux
candidates donc devons payer des
pénalités financières
mais là le résultat est absolument
inattendu et en fait je pense d'abord
c'est une volonté politique de la part
du parti
en marche pas du mouvement en marche de
plus il avait une commission de
l'investiture qui était paritaire temps
qu'ils ont fait vraiment bien
l'intention d'investir non seulement
autant de femmes que d'hommes et
d'investir aussi l'aide de répartir les
circonscriptions en fonction qu'elle
était plus ou moins gagnable il en est
aussi sur des ignares et près de syrte
en dollar titulaire aussi et pas
forcément de supplément au dessus des
autres parce que de quelques sorties
politiques qui jouent le jeu
on a tendance à proposer des suppléantes
que les suppléants et oui et là bon et
en plus il n'avait pas non plus vraiment
beaucoup de sortants a placé parce que
le problème des partis traditionnels
c'est comme ils ont beaucoup de sortants
les sortants sont majoritairement des
hommes donc il ils ont priorité ensuite
on place encore quelques personnes et
puis les femmes ou les plats sans suite
pour essayer de faire la parité
voilà là si on prend le département des
yvelines un fort renouvellement il ya
aussi un peu coûteux femme si on prend
juste le sud du département le secteur
couvert aparté les fils on peut recenser
trois députés aient eu ses députés ces
femmes vous les avez rencontré déjà ce
que vous avez échangé avec elle non pas
encore non non en fait sur le
département il ya il ya huit femmes sur
alors que dans l'ancienne législature
c'était deux femmes sur 12 donc c'est un
grand c est également un grand
bouleversement oui je maintiens que vous
les avez déjà sollicité oui oui mais
enfin bon on les sollicite mais leur
parler pour l'instant je n'ai pas de
retour l'instant mais vous vous battez
néanmoins pour obtenir cette parité on
va juste faire un petit rappel
historique il qu'il honorait puis on
aurait bien aimé que elles répondent
surtout au questionnaire que l'on a
envoyé nous avons envoyé à tout à tous
les candidats redoutent un manifeste qui
recense un petit peu nos revendications
en termes vous devrez la parité dans
toutes les assemblées on n'y est pas
encore parce que les communes de moins
de 1000 habitants mais pas la parité on
l'a pas encore à l'assemblée nationale
on l'a pas encore au sénat et surtout
dans les intercommunalités qui reste le
point noir
ensuite on aimerait bien qu'il n'y ait
pas de cumul des mandats dans le temps
afin que soit limitée à 2
on l'a apparemment s'oriente vers une
limitation
r3 et en plus on aimerait quand même
encore des améliorations d'un statut et
les lieux parce que nous les personnes
qui ont répondu c'est que c'est le
retour à l'emploi une fois qu'on a
terminé le mandat c'est le gros problème
là il vous allez avoir plein de députés
qui étaient là qui sont confrontés à ce
problème
enfin dans les mairies il ya énormément
de le maire et le maire adjoint qui sont
confrontés à ce problème tous les six
ans voilà je refais ce rappel historique
que je voulais juste faire 1946
premières élections ouvertes aux femmes
6,8 pour cent seulement à l'assemblée
nationale voilà pour que chacun mesure
la la progression même si elle était
longue
avant d'arriver à ce chiffre aujourd'hui
vous le disais vous avez devant c'est un
peu la suite des questions aujourd'hui
c'est c'est bien mais ce n'est pas
suffisant et vont rester vigilante parce
qu'il ya du travail à faire
rien dans les collectivités locales à la
mairie ou intercommunalités et au sénat
c'est parce qu'il veut qu est ce que ça
va donner au sénat y avait 70 femmes
dans une exposition tambre il ya
beaucoup de contournement de la loi nous
on aimerait bien que ce soient les modes
de scrutin qui change
on aimerait bien que soient inscrits en
liste sont des grandes circonscriptions
alors qu'actuellement c'est les
départements quand on y accueille troyes
c'est un homme une femme un homme et des
listes dissidentes avec des hommes en
tête et vous voilà tous les
détournements pour que sur les hommes
qui sont élevés par les femmes
l'association a été fondée en 1992 et
mâcon journée sur ce moment de création
comment a été accueilli la création de
l'association que vous avez présidé
aussi d'ailleurs accepté bien vu ou mal
vu aussi bas non mais à cette époque là
il y avait un grand mouvement pour la
parité et ça avait commencé par le
conseil de l'europe qui avait fait
qu'ils avaient commencé à parler de
parité en 1989 et en 92 il y avait une
grande conférence à athènes où il y
avait des ministres femmes européennes
qui s'étaient réunis et on a commencé
réellement à parler de la parité donc en
fait nous avons pas été la seule
association à ce moment là à se créer
dont il ya plusieurs associations et
c'était en vue de faire changer la
constitution puisque il y avait eu il ya
vu un projet de loi pour qu'il y ait 25
août à 2 25% de femmes dans l'est
dans les municipalités ça avait été
rejetée par le conseil constitutionnel
donc il fallait absolument nom de
l'universalisme républicain n'avait pas
distingué hommes et femmes
voilà ce qui fait que mais enfin il
fallait faire quelque chose parce que
entre 45 et 50 ans plus tard il n'y
avait pas plus de femmes députées donc
il fallait vraiment faire quelque chose
d'autant qu'il fallait une volée une
volonté législative pour faire quelque
chose et donc en fait nous avons
participé à un grand mouvement
notre association un grand mais vous
avez le sentiment que le résultat obtenu
aujourd'hui peut-être durable ou que
est-ce que vous avez visiblement en tout
cas ce sentiment que les choses ont
changé et pour de bon cette fois ci
parce que dans les utilitaires je pense
que dans la mythique dans les mentalités
maintenance a réellement changé de toute
façon vos gains déjà tous les médias
parlent de parité la parité maintenant
on en parle dans d autres domaines de la
société on en parle dans les
associations dans toutes les
institutions finalement dans leur dos ou
quatre dans les entreprises du cac40
maintenant il semblerait qu'on ait
atteint 43 % de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration ce qui est quand même
voilà les crasses grâce à la loi
finalement donc finalement quand on veut
on y arrive en fait c'est ça c'est une
question de volonté politique
et apparemment c'est ce qui a marché il
est vrai que la volonté politique reste
mais nous sommes au 21ème siècle donc on
peut difficilement quand même revenir en
arrière dans ce domaine aujourd'hui pour
juste pour conclure le coeur de votre
combat justement ces prochaines
élections sénatoriales notamment non
nous on ne te contrat principal son
monde et les intercommunalités parce que
c'est le vrai là y avait un véritable
déficit de parité était le système
électoral actuel ne nous convient pas et
bon le problème c'est qu'il ya que 16%
de femmes r d'ailleurs nous sommes en
train justement de faire une recherche
action en bretagne sur ce sujet pour
essayer de comprendre et agir parce
qu'on aimerait bien que en 2020 c'est
bientôt mais il ya quand même plus de
femmes mères donc plus de femmes têtes
de liste et ça c'est toujours problème
et peut-être de liste on présidente il
ya peu de femmes maires il ya que 8% de
femmes présidentes des intercoms 10%
dans les départements enfin voilà et
encore du travail mais ce que l'on
attend demain peut-être qu'une femme
sera élu au perchoir et on verra demain
vous verra-t-on également dans les
présidences des commissions voilà que ce
soit bien que ce soit équilibré c'était
la der c'était le cas dans la dernière
législature mais présidences de
commission merci pour cet art plateau et
nous continuerons à parler du travail
que vous menez avec l'association elle
aussi régulièrement sur cette antenne et
puis et puis vous disiez le lulz cela
avance mais il ya encore du travail en
tout cas de la vigilance nous allons
parler santé
à présent le 7-8 ans vitesse poursuit
[Musique]
jérôme andré président directeur hf
prévention ou pardon votre actualité
directeur parce qu'on est aussi une
présidence selon la parité pour revenir
sur le sujet d'avant ça m'a aidé pour la
transition merci donc j'avais fait
exprès pour ça que j'ai du président
voilà votre actualité c'est sont ses
nouveaux locaux à trappes qui seront
inaugurés en fin de semaine on va y
venir aussi mais l'occasion est aussi
donnée aujourd'hui de parler prévention
prévention du sida à la veille elle de
l'été selon la haute autorité de santé
dans un rapport de mars 2010 est à près
de cent cinquante mille personnes sont
aujourd'hui atteintes par le vih dans le
pays a donc trente mille sans le savoir
le nombre d'infections ne baisse pas il
est stable un peu plus de sept mille
nouveaux cas chaque année dont 40% sont
diagnostiqués tardivement doux à
l'importance de se faire dépister
régulièrement la prévention à la veille
de l'été est une période critique
c'est une période critique en réalité
parce que les gens vont il fait beau il
ya du soleil chez chocolat sera dénudé
et là pour le coup on est vraiment dans
une problème qui est fait un problème
qui est vraiment différent c'est à dire
que les gens ne pensent pas aux risques
et effectivement les campagnes d'été
sont toujours très compliqué il ya
solidays qui vient de se finir
en fréquentation pas forcément automne
et puis on a effectivement donc l'été
qui est générateur en général de
nouveaux cas de contamination entre
avant on avait plutôt tendance à dire 6
à 7000 cas maintenant on parle plutôt de
7 à 8000
on n'est pas sur un rebond de l'épidémie
mais le problème c'est que ça fait quand
même plus de dix ans qu'on parle de 6 à
7000 cas de contamination en maintenant
cette année 1000 mais du coup ça ne
baisse pas et ça pour le coup ça reste
inquiétant parce que il y à beaucoup
d'efforts de prévention qui est fait
mais pour le coup on voit que
malheureusement l'épidémie est toujours
présente et outre le vih on a aussi
maintenant toutes les ist qui pullulent
avec effectivement le retour de la
syphilis le retour de l'hépatite art
dans certaines communautés des
problématiques d'hépatite b alors qu'on
a des vaccins sur l'hépatite à
l'hépatite b
on a le papillomavirus aussi en à un
vaccin
malheureusement deux wagons devait
alexine pas assez la couverture
vaccinale en france est relativement
trop faible ce relâchement des
comportements s'explique comment on en
parle régulièrement mais c'est humain
on se dit que c'est bon que finalement
il existe des traitements et on peut
faire avec
non je faisais les campagnes qui sont
passés aussi que les campagnes
malheureusement les pouvoirs publics
certaines associations pendant des
années on dit le sida c'est dans telle
ou telle communauté
moi j'ai du mal avec ça parce que vous
le savez organisent entre sept et dix
mille dépistages chaque année notamment
dans les universités les centres
commerciaux les choeurs de cité et quand
un centre de dépistage trouve en moyenne
0 2 % de ces patients séropositifs
nouvellement diagnostiqués à chaque
prévention dans les universités et a
presque 2%
donc on voit qu'il ya un ratio qui n'est
pas logique qui n'est pas normal on a de
plus en plus de jeunes qui sont
contaminés et on a aussi les plus de 45
ans parce qu'ils changent de vie parce
qu'ils se disent je n'ai pas utilisé le
préservatif avec ma femme
et puis à 45 ans se remet un peu en
cause et puis on devient un peu frivole
et l'a donc du coup cédé public qu'on a
du mal à atteindre en dehors des centres
commerciaux
il ya des centres commerciaux qui jouent
le jeu et c'est pas le cas sur tous les
territoires
il ya des universités qui jouent le jeu
en ile de france c'est qu'elle sait
quasiment partout où effectivement on
fait du dépistage mais on sent qu'il ya
un malaise effectivement sur ces
dépistages d'où le fait d'avoir des
nouvelles missions de dépistage et
aujourd'hui on va pouvoir dépister aussi
notamment les ist oui vous allez
intervenir sur un champ plus large
qu'aujourd'hui on verra par la suite le
ministère de la santé vous a confié une
mission est alors effectivement donc il
ya l'hépatite c qu'on a entamée depuis
le début de l'année alors l'hépatite c
c'était assez confidentiel nous disait
ton et en fin de compte on se rend
compte qu'il ya pas mal de cas de
contamination va aussi rentrer dans un
programme de l'om s l'organisation
mondiale de la santé notamment sur la
syphilis et puis ça c'est pour le
domaine santé sexuelle mais on va aussi
sur des nouvelles aires thérapeutiques
comme le diabète la nutrition les
problèmes cardiovasculaires parce que l'
expertise d'hachette prévention qui est
d'aller au devant des publics et de
pouvoir effectivement proposer des tests
directement sur les lieux et une
expertise qui s'exporte
de la même manière que virus war qui est
le game center là on a bientôt la v2 qui
sort eh bien oui effectivement on
réfléchit aussi à des versions pour la
nutrition comment mieux manger parce
qu'on se rend compte que des halles des
ateliers cuisine des fois ça suffit pas
comment aussi donc mieux éduquer les
gens parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui manque
c'est quand même très largement des
plans d'éducation large et on espère
effectivement que nos gammes 'changer
pourront contribuer donc à cela et si
vous voulez avoir des renseignements des
êtres des contacts l'adresse est
affichée il ya un instant en bas de
l'écran cet attrape ses nouveaux locaux
vous allez une erreur une semaine
nouveaux locaux pour le siège national
puisque nous on est des enfants
de saint quentin pour la plupart donc on
a effectivement des nouveaux locaux pour
le siège national et on continue à
recevoir le public à l'institut de
promotion de la santé oms garde de
locaux à la css réglages mais
effectivement comme on est de plus en
plus nombreux
et comme on a besoin effectivement de
s'étendre en termes de taille
l'agglomération de saint quentin qui
héberge déjà achète prévention ile de
france ouest et nos campings
enfin un camping-car lampard dont on
pouvait pas non plus héberger tout et
puis c'est vrai qu'on va avoir des
nouveaux camions comme les camions santé
de la femme donc ça c'est aussi un
nouveau volet qui arrivent chez nous au
mois d'octobre
c'est sûr qu'à un moment donné faut être
autonome et se diversifier et donc d'où
l'arrivée de ces nouveaux locaux et on
viendra vous voir dans ces nouveaux
locaux inauguration en fin de semaine on
en parlera dans le journal très
rapidement merci germandrée l'adresse je
voulais dire c'est afficher hf
prévention et puis la formule vous la
connaissez mais elle est toujours
d'actualité sortez couverts merci à vous
d'être venu ce soir la fin du set 8
invités
[Musique]